[Music]
it's time for early RTX 390 TI buyers to
feel really bad because the short
version of the review of the RTX 490 is
that we're seeing rasterization uplift
at 4K anywhere between 40 and 75% versus
a 3090 ti so a big jump there and
although Nvidia isn't allowing anyone to
review the partner model cards until
tomorrow uh the founders Edition can be
reviewed today thinking of course about
EVGA recently saying that they felt like
they were competing with Nvidia this
kind of rings true there either way the
founders Edition is in for testing
rumors leading up to launch of the
$1,600 card were largely centered around
thermals and power which are closely
related so we'll be looking at those in
depth today with transient spikes uh in
the scope for analysis as well as the
usual gaming and R tracing performance
tests let's get started before that this
video is brought to you by be quiet and
their silent Wings 4 fans the silent
Wings 4 fans Market themselves as being
useful on radiators Tower coolers and
cases alike the fans have a six-pole
motor and use a fluid Dynamic bearing
which helps with the noise profile and
with longevity the fans use anti
vibration mounts for reduced the noise
transfer to the case and have a rated
lifespan of
$300,000s learn more at the link in the
description below so first that we
captured too much data for this review
we're actually going to run another
video with pressure tests some flatness
testing of the cold plate we'll looking
at frequency curves uh noise and
Acoustics and more in a separate piece
but this one is is already pretty
detailed for power thermals and gaming
uh we have over 30 charts just for
gaming in here about 30 anyway and
remember that as we ramp into this the
cost of Alternatives currently is more
important than the original MSRP of
things like a 6950 XT or like a 3090 ti
so just quickly glancing at Amazon as
we're writing this review we saw that an
RTX 380 today new in box cost about $700
to $740 on average in the US the 3090 is
about $980 or so right now just on
Amazon quick search and the 390 TI is in
the range of $1,100 to $1,300 the $490
at $1,600 obviously very expensive
you're looking at a 60% increase in
price over say a 3090 right now today
new in box and Nvidia still and its
Partners have too many 30 series cards
so that's going to be true for at least
a little while so that Nvidia is
launching the RTX 490s Standalone
without the 480s with it should give
everyone pause on pulling the trigger at
least moment parly the company is
clearly desperate to dump R tx30
inventory so every play is a move to
ensure that we don't end up with the
market that's overloaded with both 40
series and 30 series jamming the channel
and the reason we're bringing that up is
because they have two more cards both
called 480 coming up in probably about
November and AMD also has rdna A3 coming
up shortly as well so uh we'll want to
see how close the 480s fall to this and
things like rasterization because if you
look at like the a750 versus the a77
they're so close the 770 might as well
not exist for most people so that's all
the sort of disclaimers out of the way
now we can really get into the
performance and talk about how this
thing does because genuinely this is one
of the largest performance uplifts we've
seen generationally in many years at in
multiple Generations uh 1080ti saw huge
jump similar to this but upwards of 75%
is a massive Spike over the 390 ti so
there is real power behind this card the
the power numbers that have been
discussed those are fueling something
and it is an increase in performance now
it's time to look at it though and uh
we'll start with thermals we are leading
our review with thermal and power over
here stone is working on setting up the
transients right now so he's doing some
transient testing to see what the spikes
look like and how bad they are we'll
come back to that and then on my end
I've wired up the card with all of these
little wires running out of it these are
thermocouples that we have attached to
key components like mosfets memory
components and we're also monitoring the
GPU with software and you can see all
these cards here we've done a lot of
this type of testing in the past so
actually I'll I'll show you some of the
other cards we've done this on this is
actually one of them that we're working
on right
now that's an RK
770 and we're actually keeping this shot
for additional climate control so we can
keep it flat for ambient and for
others we have tested many of these
on the GPU shelf here so a lot of these
have been wired in the past in much the
same way but our methods have improved
now and we're using better hardware for
the monitoring and I'm excited to see
what the results are so let's get back
in
there so we have I think it's six
thermocouples hooked up right now we're
monitoring the ambient actively every
second of the test it's something we
normally do and what we're doing at the
moment is this is our ambient Thermo
couple probe it's up and away from any
heat sources how we do a lot of testing
so it's a really steady 20.0 de C plus
or minus about 0.5 and then I've got a
bunch of these wired up to memory
specifically and then these two are
wired up to ver mosfet we're running
Port Royal on Loop at the moment but
that's not the only test I'm doing and
it's also a custom Port Royal Loop so
we've increased the settings to load the
GPU specifically in different areas and
all of this will go into the thermal
charts but to show you some context for
what this actually takes to wire up
because it's a nightmare let's go over
to what I call the Arts and Crafts bench
so this is
a huge project to wire up cards with
thermal couples where I had some print
outs from our tear down video so I could
just keep it keep track of where the
thermal pads are and where everything
goes we have the exact pads brand new
clean that Nvidia used so we have the
supply of the pads we have the supply of
the uh phase change thermal interface
material so that we're able to replace
everything as needed as we do these
tests with an exact like for like that
Nvidia is using so enough of all the
setup let's get into some of the thermal
charts all right so the first test is
Port Royal as a workload with some
modified settings on the graphic side
but full stock settings on the Nvidia
side in this one the GPU core seemed to
follow a temperature Target of 70° C it
fluctuated between 66 and 72 and the GPU
hotspot temperature ran in the 80s also
fine but pushing it if you're in more of
a hot boox case the fan speed would
increase to compensate so your noise
would be higher for the memory modules
that we manually probed we mapped the
thermocouples along the edge of the
module that bordered the hottest
components nearby memory module R2 held
steady state at about 65° C that's case
temperature so for actual internal
silicon of the memory it could be as
much as about 10° higher according to
research papers previously published
within the thero couple industry even at
75 that'd be acceptable the bottom
module on the PCI slot ran in the low
60s with memory L2 in the same area as
for the mosfets on the left and the
right of the board those are running in
the upper 50s and the low 60s since fets
can take around 100 to 125 C on average
without big problems this is all
completely acceptable they're in good
range here we'll also plot our ambient
line just to sort of be transparent and
show you how controlled our lab is you
can also use this to follow the dips and
see how they're Associated here's the
bar chart with two different test
scenarios both of these were with auto
fan settings however the fans spun at
the same speed for each was 45.4%
average for the blue line and 47.0 for
the red line which is within usual
fluctuation for fan curve furm Mark with
stock settings put more load on the GPU
and the board which makes sense and it
ran hotter for the GPU core in memory
the other components impressively
maintain the same temperature like for
the memory and for the vrm components
and that was due to good thermal
balancing across the board so the GPU
temperature following that 66 to 70° C
range that indicates that is the vbios
or the firmware that Nvidia has
programmed being told to basically set
the fans along a known curve to hit that
temperature Target and that's completely
acceptable as GPU temperature for
silicon the hot spot's getting a little
warm if you put it in a a really bad
poor air flow case you will be on the
higher side it'll run louder and uh the
best solution is buy better case but
some other types of designs may do
better with that for example an AIO
solution now since Nvidia talk such big
game when going over the prototypes for
this cooler we went ham wiring it up for
thermal testing it took about 6 hours of
wiring and validation work plus four
additional of testing but we wanted to
challenge everything that Nvidia claimed
and from what we can see thermally this
card is proving itself if you look at
the lines in that first line graph we
plotted you can see how tightly together
all the memory modules and the fets are
for temperature and that's scattered
across the board so when we wired this
up it wasn't all clustered in one spot
it was across the whole PCB and that
means there's good thermal load
balancing across the PCB and some of
that comes from design changes this
generation like putting in blockers
those little North and South fins
internally that stop air recirculation
along with obviously the increase in fan
size that's a huge part of it it has
downsides like case fitment uh but
that's part of the thermal Improvement
and then obviously the fin stack being
as much surface area as it is so purely
speaking thermal ignoring everything to
do with value with gaming performance R
tracing Performance dss3 Marketing and
whatever other that gets talked
about relating to this card when it
launches purely thermally speaking the
founders Edition here seems to actually
be well-designed that actually is
critical because that is abnormal that's
the first time we've ever said that
about an AMD card or an envidia card and
certainly we've never said that about an
Intel card and this one is actually able
to compete with partner so Nvidia is now
getting to a point where it is able to
compete with Partners which is also
scary because it starts to look like
maybe EVGA knew something and just got
out at the right time if their partner
is going to be competing with them this
well so that's it for The Thermals for
now and we'll come back to The a770
Thermals later now we're going to look
at Power transients where Patrick stone
is setting up in testing the 490 for
transient spikes and previously we saw
something like 2 2 and a half X and
transients for something like a 390
master from gigabyte and that could be
potentially bad to knock your system
offline so I'll let Stone explain what
it is transients are what we're testing
for yes so when we talk about transient
spikes what we're looking for on the
hardware level is current and we want to
see how much current is coming across
these wires and uh to get a baseline for
this particular test we're using firmar
then we'll jump to video games as well
um the transients
uh on this card are going to be a little
more interesting because instead of
having three cables to work with or two
cables to work with now we got four
cables to work with and so we've got to
jump around here and there to figure out
which one's delivering the most current
and then we'll we'll use that to capture
our transient spikes um right now we're
just looking at micros seconds we're
looking for these frames of high microsc
so we got it set on a 200 microc per
Division and in fermar we're catching
things that are like 600 micr seconds
for power supply over current protection
you're really not worried about it until
you get into like the millisecond
territory but um you know well that's
why we're testing things to see if it
gets there so we'll see what happens on
the 4090 so as for what all that means
for the end user the reason we look at
Power transients is because if you get a
really bad transient spikes and you
either have a lowquality power supply or
one that's just not quite up to the
capacity needs to cover that Spike you
can end up with the system shutting down
while you're playing a game or something
something so that's why we're looking at
it let's get into the charts we
ultimately decided to clamp all four
cables using three clamps which is fine
since the rated range of the clamps
supports that division we lose a
marginal amount of accuracy in the low
single digit percentages but nothing
that'll actually affect the results we
divided the fourth Cable's 12vt lines
evenly between the three clamps for this
testing overall in our testing the power
Behavior seems well controlled the
maximum current being pulled by the card
is consistently about 33 to 40% over the
nominal power which is 450 Watts most
critically these zoomed in scope shots
show a change in Behavior looking at the
millisecond level at most we typically
see spikes inside of 100 microsc on
cards with the 4090 however the graphs
almost look inverted the longest
transient Spike we observed was 1,110
micros seconds or about 1.1 milliseconds
that's long enough to potentially knock
a borderline or lower-end power supply
offline
and much longer than we typically see in
Rainbow Six Siege on Doom we saw
approximately 500 microc La transients
this is different from what we typically
see where this one since the max Spike
we're seeing is about 40% over nominal
and for a longer period it's contrary to
the usual much shorter much spikier and
way higher power Spike like with a 3090
master from gigabyte where we saw spikes
upwards of something like 2 and 1 12x or
something like that if memory serves we
have video on it uh so this is different
and rumors had indicated spikes upwards
of 2.5 to 3x over nominal for the 4090
for this card and we're not seeing that
we weren't able to reproduce it doesn't
mean it doesn't happen we only ran this
for about 8 hours for transient testing
then we had to do all the other stuff so
someone might find something more
interesting but from what we've seen for
eight hours of work on different games
and applications it's completely
acceptable for the transients so far
it's just that duration might kick more
power spies offline uh if they don't
have the capacity to soak now some of
the rumors did come from Power spy
manufacturers and it's possible and
maybe likely that since they had early
insight to what the card would require
Nvidia probably provided them the
feedback hey it's going to be 2.5 3x
transend they freaked out said no way we
can't do it and then maybe there was
some design revision and rework there in
the time since uh also we know that the
GPS for the 490 were on 3090 TI pcbs and
the 3090 TI PC was a test platform for
the 490 maybe it wasn't up to the task
we also noticed that initial small
spikes led to the power delivery circuit
balancing the load as time progressed
and it does so in a really unique way we
saw the highest load shifting from one
cable to the next effectively
Distributing the transient heat load as
well across the individual cables
whether this was total chance or part of
the design we're not sure we'd have to
do a lot more testing but we do know
that this cable this uh adapter cable is
really important so it does have the
four sense pins in it and one of the
things that we observed was if you
connect three of these we tried getting
rid of one to see what would happen it
will still boot however you'll lose the
ability to boost the power Target so
normally you can go from 100% to 133%
Max with all four connected with only
three it drops down to just 100% with
two we weren't able to get it to boot
and post image to the screen and that's
because Nvidia is actively sensing how
many cables are connected to this ad
adapter so it is a smart adapter in that
way this isn't just a dumb plug them in
and then it just pulls the power it
wants to pull from whatever's connected
it knows what's on the other side that's
important we noticed that the power
connector responsible for the highest
current draw across that varied from
test to test which is uncommon typically
we see a dominant connector then a
secondary and a tertiary and so forth
this one demonstrated Behavior almost of
a like a feedback loop that helps to
regulate the card and its power drop so
you'll definitely want to use all four
if you get one of these and as for the
aftermarket options we haven't tested
them yet we don't know if it'll still
pull the full power if you're only
running two even though technically the
cables can handle it or what'll happen
that'll be a future thing but there's a
lot more power testing we could do here
for now let's just look at a nominal
load chart and then if anyone discovers
anything really unique on launch day
we'll continue to investigate it but for
now transience of 33% to 40% seems to be
about the norm now for the averaged
power consumption this shows the actual
power utilization over longer periods so
rather than the transient spikes upwards
of 630 WS we're looking at sustained
power tested in firmar for a torture
load the RTX 490 stock card pulls 496
Watts on average we observed 450 to 490
watts in some gaming scenarios but
closer to that 500 Mark and fur Mark
that aligns with the 390 TI results
previously and remember that this is
just the card power so slot plus pcie
cables we don't measure the whole system
in this as for the 33% power in increase
for an overclock the RTX 490 pushes
to that's unfortunate let's move on to
gaming benchmarks in Total War Warhammer
3 at 4K and high settings the RTX 490 is
entirely GPU bound which is good for
testing and runs at 125 FPS average that
has it outdoing the RTX 390 TI by 59%
and the RTX 390 by 81% the lows are also
improved significantly on the 490
however they're mostly proportional to
the average so it's nothing special here
if you bought 390 TI though for $2,000
early this year it's probably feeling
pretty bad right now they don't normally
launch them this close together the 6950
XT Trails both and the RTX 380 but will
do proportionately better at 1080P and
1440p we've also got the 2080 TI on here
where the 490 outperforms it by an
increase of 172% these are some of the
largest gains we've ever seen
generationally so regardless of price
that at least is impressive on its own
we'll talk talk about the value though
and the conclusion at 1440p the 490
isn't yet CPU bottleneck so it's still
actually showing scaling here the card
maintains a 64% improvement over the 390
TI and an 83% improvement over the 3090
similar to the 4K results the 2 136 FPS
average result has it about 100 FPS or
so over in average over the 6950 XT from
Sapphire which is a 90% Improvement
finally for the 1080p results the 490
gets cut down to a 54% lead over the 390
TI that much of a s downwards isn't
because of architecture alone but also
again because we're starting to hit that
CPU limitation this game in F1 2022 at
4K the 490 ran at 230 FPS average and
held a 70% lead over the 390 TI that's
similar to what we saw in total
Warhammer uh although a bit better for
the 490 here so it's shaping up to be
the average of 60 to 70% right now for a
rasterization lead the Boost over the
390 non TI is a 100% jump or a doubling
of frame rate performance but the 6 950x
he lands between the two in this game
and cuts the 490s lead down to 73% as
compared to its 133 FPS average entry
those are proportionately scaled on the
390 TI the 390 and the 6950 XT they're
still good on the 490 but they're not
proportionately scaled with the average
frame rate this chart will show us frame
time consistency it's the most empirical
way to look at the user experience as it
shows the frame to frame time required
in milliseconds to render each of those
frames which just shown as one point on
the line the RTX 490 mostly clusters
around 4 to 5 milliseconds but regularly
spikes to 9 milliseconds these aren't
noticeable to the player typically we
see that people observe 8 to 12
millisecond jumps as potential stutters
but they are enough to throw that 1% out
of proportion that we saw earlier
there's a single Spike to 26
milliseconds that is noticeable to the
player as a slight hitch or stutter but
we normally have to see multiple of
these in a test period to actually
become concerned about them for now it's
something to pay attention to as we
iterate through the next charts the 6950
XT plots just as kind of a baseline for
another device this one is mostly
consistent throughout the test with
fewer excursions though it does have a
few excursions of its own moving to
1440p now the RTX 490 is approaching the
CPU bind which is in the 290s for FPS
average that means we're CPU bound on
and off throughout this test but not for
the entirety of it the 490 holds a 27%
lead still over the 6950 XD but that's
cut down from 73% previously some of
that is AMD gaining at these lower
resolutions but most of that is a CPU
bind we won't learn much new at 1080p
other than a reminder that the 6950 XE
and the 6900 XE have an advantage over
the 390 TI at this resolution Shadow the
tomb Raiders up now at 4K the 490
maintains a 70% lead over the RTX 390 TI
it's consistent with the previous
results the 6950 XT and the 390 are both
similarly ranked and if you were on an
RTX 280 TI previously you'd see a 164%
increase in frame rate moving to the
4090 almost leaked a new card there it's
just called the 490 it's not the ti
let's all move along before anybody from
Nvidia hears that this is where we jump
to a regular reminder that if you're
happy with your computer today there's
no need to upgrade right now even though
something like this is shiny new and
impressive because if you look at that
chart we just saw everything on there is
in playable territory you'll do just
fine the frame rates are getting
ridiculous at this point with these
types of cards until you enable features
like RT so it is something to really
think about out do you actually need to
upgrade and especially do you need to go
this high end if there's stuff like 307s
out there for cheaper now than they used
to be 1440p reduces the 490 knot TI
which doesn't exist lead over the 390 Ti
from 70% to 27% a clear CPU cap the 6950
XT also encroaches on the 490 and it now
outranks the 390 TI as well as we're
bound here we'll move on but the value
is clearly dismal if you're playing
under a constraint like this and buying
a 490 just does not make any sense just
to show it since we have it here's the
1080p chart it's also bound obviously
and everything above the 380 Mark is
incomparable and useless because it's
being limited by the CPU but gives you
some perspective of where your
limitations might lie Rainbow Six Siege
at 4K gives us an older dx11 title to
look at but one that's still popular
this game has the 490 at 355 FPS average
leading the 3090 TI by only about 47%
only there compared to the previous
results it's not spectacular for the
price considering the 390 TI is
currently closer to like 900 to 1,000
bucks and the 490 outperforms the 6950
XT by 86% here in average FPS which sets
a mark to watch for lower resolutions at
1440p it's still not CPU bound the 490
leads the 390 TI by 41% consistent with
the 4K result previously the gains in
Rainbow Six Siege are just that much
worse than in other games which shows
that the pi and the game itself May
dictate some of your scaling in a way
that can wipe out most of the value of
the 490 and again we won't spend much
time on 1080p it's CPU bound now it did
climb another 50 FPS first before
hitting the CPU bind with these graphic
settings uh but it's bound nonetheless
the gap between the 6950 XT and the 390
TI has shrunken here although the 390 TI
carries better lows than the AMD
Hardware not that it is noticeable at
this frame rate anyway and if you want
better value you buy something further
down the stack here's another game where
the scaling isn't as impressive as those
earlier 70% numbers in Horizon zero Dawn
at 4K we saw a limitation scaling at 53%
gain over the 39 DTI and were're not CPU
bound that's uncharacteristic of the
earlier results it's close but it's just
not quite there 1440p shows us the limit
at 180 FPS average with the 6950 XT also
bouncing off of that limit the 6900xt
and the 390 TI are close enough that
some frames are likely getting capped
but not all of them so these are all BAS
basically the same clearly you should
not buy a 4090 if you're going to play
in a scenario like this it's waste of
money 1080p is fully capped same thing
nothing new to see here 490 looks like
it's actually doing worse than the 390
in this one in reality it isn't it's
just that they're all limited that we
can't see scaling they're tripping over
their own frames as the CPU tries to
keep up and you end up with a stack that
you can't differentiate Final Fantasy at
4K is up now and this one maybe
shockingly we were still GPU bound the
game is so easy to run that we thought
we might actually be totally CPU limited
even at 4K but it's still GPU targeted
at high resolutions the RTX 490 ran at
214 FPS average which positions it 75%
ahead of the 390 TI's 122 FPS average
that's better scaling than we've seen
elsewhere maybe partly thanks to dx11
Nvidia has always done
disproportionately well on dx11 since
that API requires more driver work to
run well the lead over the 6950 XT is
88% with the 3090 getting doubled
cleanly by the 490 at 1440p we're
hitting the CPU buying the 490 runs at
235 FPS average which is functionally
the same as the 220 result we had on the
390 ti so there's no real difference
here and we'll skip 1080 this time it's
the same we also ran GTA 5 at all three
resolutions but only 4K matters since
the engine is capped at 187.5 FPS
average makes basically everything the
same the RTX 490 ran at the full cap
here dropping almost zero frames you
have to realize we've been running this
Benchmark since 2015 now on gpus we've
never seen a card to hold base basically
the engine cap like this the lead over
the 39 TI is only 38% so in that regard
it's not worth it the value doesn't
scale like in other games because we're
artificially limited on the engine the
CPU isn't capped either just to be clear
it's only Rage that's capped and not
mine but like the name of the game
engine my rage is uncapped there's no
cap No Cap okay no capping now we get
into the really complicated testing
which is Ray tracing and dlss or FSR XS
test and those three sets of initialisms
are why this has gotten so complex so
not only do we have to test for just
pure rasterization we also need to test
for rate tracing but then because
features like dlss are so prominent now
we have to enable those and there's
different ones for each vendor so this
has become a massive Matrix of really
messy tests to run we've done our best
to distill it down into a few sets of
games to give you a wide picture
performance let's take a look we'll
start with control which came back as
one of the most played RT games when he
pulled our community you all recently on
YouTube Community posts cyberp Punk was
one of the other most popular we'll test
that too starting with 4K and without
dlss the RTX 490 ran at 76 FPS average
here that's with rton now the Lowe's are
spaced out extremely well on all of
these devices keeping strong rank thanks
to the game engine and the build itself
from the developers that is the 490
outperforms the 390 TI by about 60% here
here and the 3090 by a staggering 86%
the RTX 380 is next in the list with the
6950 XT at 31 FPS average which allows
the 490 and Improvement of about 144%
int didn't make the cut for this game
but it's in some of our other tests at
1440p the 490 jumped to 148 FPS average
roughly doubling from its 4K frame rate
previously that has it 61% ahead of the
RTX 390 TI about the same as the 4K
result they're scaling in Step so the
jump over the 6950 XT would scale and
step as well except for amd's
architectural Advantage where the
Improvement is reduced to 127% from the
144 previously and now we're at 1080p
the 490 had its lead reduced to 29% over
the 390 TI a clear Mark of a bottleneck
elsewhere in the system everything
tested thus far is playable with these
settings at 1080p even without the
support of dlss or FSR and there's just
no benefit to a 490 here that's
meaningful at this resolution f 2022 is
back now this time with rate Trace
settings remember that this chart cannot
be compared to the previous F1 charts
those do not use RT settings we get
emails about this every time we publish
reviews there are RT charts and non-rt
charts they can't be compared the rate
tracing result at 4K has the 490 running
an incredible Gap over the 390 TI
forming a depressing Rift for pre-priced
drop buyers the Improvement is
75% over the 3090 TI which came out this
year the 390 is next and generationally
against the non-ti the Improvement is
105% the closest AMD card is currently
the 6950 XT at 31 FPS average Intel's
Arc makes an appear here as well but
it's nearly fallen off the chart already
at 17 FPS 1440p the 490 leads the 390 TI
at 70% the lead against the 280 TI is
200% and that card wasn't too dissimilar
of a launch price at $1,200 when
factoring in inflation over the last few
years even been ignoring inflation we'd
be at a 33% price increase for MSRP for
the 4090 for a 70% RT performance jump
and not that the 2080 TI was ever on a
recommended list anyway things matter
last at 1080 so the 490 is only 27%
ahead of the 390 TI here there's a loss
of scaling we have an increase in CPU
workload as well with rt and so we're
seeing a CPU bind cyberpunk 2077 is up
next and this was one of the most played
RT games in our community questionnaire
that we posted recently we used dlss and
FSR for this one and then is using FSR
at the moment instead of xss cuz it's
not really ready we're using the quality
settings at equal resolution scaling so
in other words at 4K it's scaling up for
1440p at 4K the RTX 490 ran at 79 FPS
average with dlss 2 the existing one
this is without D lss3 testing because
that's basically an alpha or a beta
depending on how you look at it and the
cyberpunk team isn't really ready with
it either so that has the 490 again at
about 76% ahead of the 390 TI it's about
170% ahead of the 6950 XT so nvidia's
hardware and dlss combination pushes it
pretty far ahead Intel's
a770 technically is on the chart but
let's move on at 1440p it runs at 136
FPS average to the 390 TI 80 FPS that's
with the ultra settings and dlss for
both so the 390 TI ends up allowing the
490 a big lead again the 390 though the
non-ti wasn't too far back from the ti
at 1080p we're hitting a CPU bind again
increased work on the CPU the 490 still
holds a significant lead but it's
getting diminished here finally here's
Tomb Raider this one has Ray tracing
enabled as well we'll just flash through
the results on the screen you can pause
if you're interested this review is long
enough as is but the 490 saw about the
same percent scaling of the others uh
75% over the 390 TI once again at least
until scaling got caught at 1080 okay so
wrapping up then first of all DL ss3 was
a lot of marketing talk and there was a
good amount of in that
presentation the keynote because kind of
like RT we're not really going to see
dss3 truly hitting the market uh with
this launch there's some stuff out there
not a lot it's also a lot of Alpha and
beta and it doesn't work perfectly so
just let's just factor that out right
now and ignore it much like with the 20
series launch you ignore RT in most
cases we're seeing 40 to 75% gains over
something like a 3090 TI in 4k depends
on the game some of them are last like
Total War Warhammer but in a lot of them
we're seeing those higher values now at
lower resolutions this is truly
pointless this this is like you can be
on the best CPU and if you're not
playing at 4K or 1440 with a relatively
high graphics quality game you are going
to be CPU bound so that's where you need
to know your use case if you are not
really pushing Graphics quality and
resolution this is a waste of money for
you plain and simple just like the
Titans always have been as well at 4K
that's where you start to see the actual
gains and obviously with features like R
tracing so uh whether this is actually
worth it we have not really talked about
that yet this is an expensive card it is
functionally in that Titan class where
historically you go this isn't a gaming
GPU and that's true if you look at
something like a 3090 a 3090 TI we've
never said buy this one we've always
said grab the one lower down from it so
in those examples the lower end stuff
launched first so like a 3080 or uh a
980 a 1080 stuff like that came out
before these monster flagships did like
this one Nvidia switched it this time
and this came out first which we think
probably means if we had the data for a
4080 today we'd probably be taking the
same stance as previously where we go
save the money buy the cheaper non Titan
non TI class 10 a TI notwithstanding
that was a mistake they'll never make
again uh and move with one of those so
right now we're not really comfortable
making a full value judgment until we
have the 4080 so we're we're kind of in
that let's I'll just wait and see be
patient see what happens with the 480s
and with rdna 3 cuz that's going to be
really interesting with multi chip but
Nvidia is in a strong strong spot with
the architecture generationally it's
just the value comes into question when
you launch only the absolute Flagship
and traditionally that's not what you do
as a company like Nvidia as for the
thermal design it is actually excellent
it's weird to say like we said earlier
Founders edition cards reference cards
we have never been in favor of the
thermal design on those Nvidia really uh
did kind of fix this one it's massive as
a result but then so are the partner
models and that begins the interesting
discussion of can Partners truly compete
with a company that has infinite
resources as one of nvidia's thermal
Engineers recently said uh to do things
like fan simulations when the partners
are just sort of picking from the supply
that's out there on the market so that's
going to be a really interesting fight
to see we won't actually the answer to
that until we get partner models in
power so the transients were not bad
from what we saw it's possible there's
something hiding there that we didn't
discover please keep us informed if you
see something from someone we'll look
into it but for now we didn't see any
transients that were concerning the
power consumption is high it's 450 to
500 watts and you're going to need to
accommodate transients of at least 30 to
40% uh for pretty long durations of 500
micros seconds up to 11 100 mic 1.1
milliseconds so that's abnormal that's
kind of new is that duration of
transients so that's it for this one
we'll talk more about value once we can
see more of the market shape up but
right now keep in mind the 30 series
which Nvidia is happy to sell you as
well has come down in price as have the
6,000 series from AMD those are
seriously worth considering at the
moment uh even if you buy it new in box
and paying that slight premium over
something used if you don't feel
comfortable to used market and we don't
blame you thanks for watching as always
you can subscribe for more go to store.
Gamers access.net to help us out
directly by grabbing things like our mod
mats to build your PCS on or you can go
to patreon.com / Gamers Nexus to help
fund our reporting check back for more
we'll see you all next time